Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Korean thriller film
called “Everyone is there.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
Lisa is a timid and shy sixteen-year-old. In
the opening scene, she is running down a hill
in the middle of the woods. Her clothes are
torn and her face is covered in injuries.
Suddenly, she trips on a stair
and falls several feet below.
With her remaining strength, she begs
someone for help and falls unconscious.
In the following scene, Lisa is in the hospital.
The severity of her injuries is clearly visible
in broad daylight. Fortunately, a bypasser found
her in the woods and brought her to the hospital.
Outside, two police officers are discussing the
case. Judging by the previous bullying reports,
the cops are sure that Lisa was
bullied by the girls of her school.
But before advancing the case, they will
have to get an official statement from Lisa.
They have also tried to contact Lisa’s parents but
it turns out that her mother died a few years ago
and her father is overseas. He is not involved in
her life and doesn’t care even if she dies.
When she regains consciousness, the head
police detective, Mr. Kim introduces himself.
He asks her several questions about her health
and the incident that happened yesterday but
Lisa remains quiet throughout the interrogation.
They are interrupted by her homeroom teacher
Miss Lee. She urges the officer to go away and
let the girl rest for a while. Malice is clear
in her intention when she tries to stop Lisa
from giving away who actually did this to her.
Mr. Kim then notices three middle-aged women
in the doorway. They are the mothers of the
girls who are suspected of bullying Lisa. He
figures that they want to threaten Lisa or
bribe her into not saying anything.
He asks them to go away since they are
legally not allowed to meet the victim but the
women are adamant. Their husbands are people
with power and money which makes them believe
their daughters can get away with anything.
Mr. Kim states that their daughters were the ones
who called Lisa to the mountain but the mothers
nonchalantly claim that the girls were just
hanging out. When the argument gets heated, Lisa
asks them to go away because she wants to rest.
After the incident, the homeroom teacher Miss Lee
meets the school principal. Both of them know
very well that Lisa was bullied. To save the
school’s reputation, the principal wants Miss
Lee to transfer Lisa to another school when she
returns. He hides his corruption by pretending
to be worried about the bullies’ future.
A few weeks later, Lisa recovers from the injuries
and can finally walk around. Mr. Kim has tried to
ask her about the incident several times in the
past week but Lisa hasn’t broken her silence.
Because of lack of proper evidence, the case
is handed to some counseling guidance teacher,
and the bullies are let free again.
One night, Lisa lets the negative thoughts
get the best of her. She tries to commit
the unthinkable but has to stop when a
lady walks into her room. The lady is the
counseling guidance teacher, Miss So-mi.
So-mi has seen a lot of students like Lisa
and helped them live after being traumatized
by a similar incident. She isn’t like any normal
guidance teacher, she was also bullied in school
and knows how it feels like to be weak. Hence, she
helps her students take revenge on the bullies.
Initially, she doesn’t seem to feel sorry for
Lisa. She makes her remember the events of the
night which in turn makes Lisa break down
crying. When she calms down, So-mi asks her
to be alive until she returns again.
On the day Lisa is being discharged,
she is visited by the leader of the bullies,
f. She has brought her new school uniform,
knowing that her old one is torn. The girl shows
no remorse for almost killing Lisa and tells her
she is better off dead. Before leaving, she
also threatens her to keep away from the police.
After she leaves, So-mi enters the room, having
heard all their conversation. She brings Lisa
to her house and helps her settle in. After
that, Lisa goes to the neighborhood where her
mother used to live before her death.
She is reminiscing about her past when a
passerby catches her attention. She follows the
girl and soon finds out she is her identical twin,
Jenny. Lisa tries to reunite with her
but Jenny walks away uninterested.
It is revealed that the girls’ parents got
divorced before they were born. The couple
was not on good terms, so the father never wanted
anything to do with Lisa and Jenny. But with time,
the mother’s financial condition got weaker.
Hence, she left Lisa at her fathers’ home
and started living with Jenny. The sisters never
met after the incident and Lisa had to live with
her father who thought of her as a burden.
The next day, So-mi follows Jenny to a convenience
store and notices her shoplifting. She stops her
outside and asks her for help. Even when told
that her sister was almost bullied to death, Jenny
remains uninterested in the conversation. She only
agrees to help when So-mi offers her money.
In the evening, the three meet at So-mi’s house.
She suggests they live together for a week or so
until the plan comes to a conclusion. Jenny is not
a fan of the idea but agrees to do it anyway. But
then, she is told she will have to go to school as
Lisa to teach the bullies a lesson.
Jenny dropped out of school a year ago.
To her, no amount of money is worth going
to school again. She refuses to cooperate
and storms off the apartment. A few minutes
later, she receives a video in a group chat.
The video is of Lisa getting bullied. A group of
girls tear her clothes, shove her to the ground,
and kick her repeatedly while a girl with
an obnoxious laugh films everything.
This makes Jenny so mad that she returns
to the apartment and calls Lisa a coward.
The video reminds Lisa of the traumatic night and
makes her hyperventilate. Seeing her twin in such
a condition, Jenny cannot help but feel bad for
her. With much determination, she asks So-mi where
she can find the girl with the obnoxious laugh.
The following day, she goes to school as Lisa.
Her classmates notice the evident change in her
behavior but no one pays much attention to her.
That is until the group of bullies enters the
classroom. The bully Nayon excitedly sits on
Jenny’s table and calls her cute for returning to
the school. Because of her laugh, Jenny realizes
that Nayeon is the girl in the video and the
one who made everyone else bully Lisa.
When the bully starts getting handsy, Jenny
slaps her to the ground with a single blow.
She then grabs her by the hair and sits on top of
her, asking her to laugh again. Following that,
she shoots a video of her while choking her
simultaneously. Her friends of bullies can
do nothing but retreat in fear.
They only stop when Miss Lee interferes. She
takes them to a private room to discipline them
but Jenny isn’t someone who obeys the teachers.
When she and Miss Lee are alone, she approaches
her with a pen, subtly threatening to stab her.
Miss Lee stammers in fear as Jenny calls
her out for being unfair to Lisa.
Later that day, Jenny returns home and shows
Lisa the video of Nayeon. Lisa doesn’t know
how to feel about it because she doesn’t
support violence, even when it is projected
towards her biggest bully. So-mi warns Jenny
to not do anything of such sort again because
it might get her sister in trouble.
The next day is the twins’ birthday.
They get themselves a cake and bond for the
first time in their lives. Lisa tells Jenny
how hard her life has been because she never
got any kind of love from her parents. Jenny
sympathizes with her since her life in poverty
with her mother has also not been ideal.
The next morning, Jenny is asleep so
Lisa decides to go to school on her
own. She believes that since Nayeon was taught a
lesson, she won’t mess with her again. At school,
Nayeon’s mother is with the principal discussing
a way to transfer Lisa to another school. The
woman is afraid that she will try to take
revenge on her daughter and wants her gone as
soon as possible. A corrupt principal assures
her to take care of the situation. Meanwhile,
Lisa overhears their conversation from the
doorway and runs to the bathroom in tears. There,
she bumps into Nayeon before locking herself
inside a stall. Nayeon, who has been wanting to
take revenge, dumps a bucket of water on her.
Lisa returns home wet and falls to the ground in
exhaustion. So-mi helps her while Jenny glows
red in anger. She immediately calls Nayeon
and asks her to come to the mountain
if she doesn’t want the video of
her beating up Lisa on the internet.
Scared to be convicted of bullying, Nayeon
does as told. When she reaches the mountain,
Jenny hits her on the head and knocks her out.
On regaining consciousness, her hands and
legs are tied and her mouth is taped.
Jenny removes the tape from her mouth and
forcefully makes her drink a full bottle of water.
Then, she brings out another bottle filled with
acid. Nayeon cries for her life which only makes
Jenny laugh harder. She pours the acid dangerously
close to her face but promises to not kill her.
By now, Nayeon can hardly breathe and is crying
hysterically. Jenny unties her legs and asks her
to run away if she wants to stay alive. The bully
takes the chance but falls a few meters away.
Just then, Lisa arrives at the scene and tries
to free Nayeon because she doesn’t want any
more people to get hurt. Seconds later, So-mi
follows behind and is shocked at the scene.
She scolds Jenny for losing her temper
and calls an ambulance for Nayeon.
In the following scene, Jenny is
getting interrogated by the police.
Since no one saw her with the victim, she is only
a suspect. So-mi arrives and asks the officers
to let her go for the time being. The officers
decide to wait until Nayeon gains consciousness
and lets them go. Outside, Jenny claims that
she does not regret her actions to the least
and would do it again if she had the chance.
A disappointed So-mi leaves her alone and returns
home. Right after, Nayeon’s mother attacks
Jenny calling her names. Jenny smugly mocks
the lady and asks her to laugh like her daughter.
While arguing, she also slips that what she did
was only a payback. The officers realize she
is in fact the culprit. When Mr. Kim calls
her by Lisa’s name, she lashes out and claims
that the Lisa he is looking for is at home.
Later, Mr. Kim and his fellow officer are driving
back home but Kim cannot get the thought of Jenny
out of his mind. He has also noticed a significant
change in her behavior since she was in the
hospital. Suspecting that she has a doppelganger,
he drives to her house to check. However,
on reaching the place, he finds it empty. Just
then, he gets a call from the hospital, informing
him that Nayeon has gained consciousness.
She is blabbering about someone else being in the
scene when she was attacked. A flashback shows
us that Jenny was alone when Nayeon was laying
on the ground in the mountains. In fact, Jenny,
Lisa, and So-mi are all the same person. Till now,
every time Lisa was talking to either of them, she
was only talking to herself. She never had a twin
sister. After being bullied, she was so alone
and stranded that she fantasized about having
someone who cared for her. Soon, the fantasy
changed into obsessiveness and she developed
a multiple personality disorder. Meanwhile, So-mi
is an actual person. She is a guidance officer
and the only person who helped Lisa. But
she never met Lisa at the hospital. Lisa
imagined her being there to tackle loneliness
and eventually added her to her personality.
The court finds out what exactly is wrong with
Lisa and she ends up in therapy. She drops out
of school and focuses on her mental health. We
see a clip of her talking to a therapist about
her past trauma in great detail. She has finally
healed from it. In the last scene, the real So-mi
drops her at the airport. Lisa is flying to
a different city to start a new life.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the channel
out. Thanks for watching.